it is a major major day in American
history today and we will get to it
momentarily quick correction earlier
this week hearing my analysis of the UK
elections I said Jeremy Corbyn has
resigned as the leader of the Labour
Party he said he will resign but has not
yet resigned I apologise for that
mistake the rest of the analysis remains
as I made it earlier this week today the
House of Representatives is expected to
formally vote to impeach president
Donald Trump it may carry over until
tomorrow
Republicans starting off the hearings
this morning with a number of attempts
to delay various obstructive attempts
including one where they opened up and
said hey we actually just moved to
adjourn let's just cancel it all and go
home of course a move that Democrats who
have the majority in the House voted
down right away depending on how long
debate goes today by the time that you
listen to today's show watch today's
show Donald Trump may already be
impeached or they may not have voted and
maybe that vote will be forthcoming
tomorrow or in the following days
yesterday rallies exploding across the
country in support of Donald Trump's
impe impeachment now I wasn't sure how
much attendance these rallies would see
but it was truly stunning huge crowds in
major cities and moderately sized cities
and towns all across the United States a
very large turnout in New York City just
one of roughly 600 events people
gathering in Times Square many protests
here in Massachusetts including in
Boston as well as in Cambridge huge
crowds in different parts of Michigan
Nashville Tennessee Washington State I
could not possibly list all of the
places because it was all over the
country in both blue states and red
states I heard from people in Oklahoma
who said that they were at impeachment
rallies people seemingly ready for when
Donald Trump will no longer be a thing
in the news anymore and of course that
will be a long time this is just the
very very beginning so the House of
Representatives may have already voted
will be voting today will be voting soon
six hours of debate scheduled on the
issue we don't know whether this is
going to extend
to beyond today but we are going to see
only the third ever impeachment of a
president of the United States of course
Andrew Johnson being impeached but
acquitted Bill Clinton impeached also
acquitted and a lot of folks incorrectly
believe that Richard Nixon was impeached
and remember Richard Nixon resigned
after it became clear because Republican
senators went to him and said listen
you've lost the support of the public
even Republican voters don't support you
if impeachment happens we will have to
convict you and that pushed Richard
Nixon to resign that is a very different
scenario than what we have today in
great part because Richard Nixon didn't
have the benefit of the 24/7
conservative media cycle social media
micro targeting
on all of these different platforms
which have made it so that 62% of Trump
is say I don't care what Trump does he
can't even hypothetically do anything
that would get me to reconsider my
support for him so let me remind
everyone that the Trump is Right is
pretending that what we are seeing right
now is mere partisanship but remember
the nationwide rallies calling for the
impeachment of Barack Obama I don't
remember them because they didn't happen
and Obama did some bad things for sure
remember the nationwide rallies calling
for the impeachment of George W Bush no
as there weren't any Bush did terrible
things and people did rally correctly
against the Iraq war but this is not
normal not every president generates
impeachment again only three have Donald
Trump being the third and not every
president catalyzes nationwide rallies
demanding that they be impeached Donald
Trump tweeting this morning more than 20
times by the time that the impeachment
debate started in the house clearly
bracing for today including saying quote
can you believe that I will be impeached
today by the radical left do-nothing
Democrats and I did nothing wrong
exclamation point a terrible thing with
a capital T read the transcripts with
attack capital T of course he has not
released the trance
from the Ukraine phone called releasing
only a fraction of it this should never
happen to another president again saying
say a prayer Trump calling for pray
religious all of a sudden now that he is
getting impeached so this is all
historic we are covering it all still
the most likely outcome is that Donald
Trump will be acquitted by the Senate
impeachment trial but I want to take
this as an opportunity because we are
seeing rallies around the country to
remind folks that we need to see crowds
and rallies just as big and bigger
nationally fighting for the climate
fighting to take back control of our
country from the corporate lobbyists
revolving door industrial complex that
we see the financialization of the
economy that we've talked about I've
talked before many times about how what
we really need you know signing
petitions is not going to achieve change
in this country calling our elected
officials alone is not going to achieve
change in this country beyond just
removing Donald Trump I'm talking about
the structural problems that we have
health care climate inequality all of
these things one of the things I've been
talking about for a long time is we need
mass rallies at urban centers and the
problem is that the system that we are
trying to change by its nature makes it
so that people can't afford to go and do
these mass rallies when people can't
miss a day of work because then that
means they don't have the money for rent
they're not going to go to their nearest
urban center and mass rally we need I've
talked about other strategies that is
serious protest strategies strategic
defaults for example and all of these
other things that we've discussed many
times crippling industry to the degree
that it makes our government have to fix
some of the problems we need to see that
kind of activism around more than just
impeaching Donald Trump I hope this will
the 600 rallies yesterday will serve as
a reminder that people can get organized
to that degree but there are going to be
some pains in it because the system is
designed to keep people in an
economically precarious State
such that they can't afford to take a
day off and to go and do this stuff so
that's the way the system works I'm
inspired by the rallies we saw yesterday
we will see the impeachment of Donald
Trump and likely the acquittal but let's
remember that the mass rallies and urban
centers should be utilized as a tool far
beyond simply saying we want Trump to go
I have something for you today that I
think you're really going to enjoy
Ivanka Trump Donald Trump's daughter who
is often in positions of power in terms
of being a spokesperson or
representative for the position of the
Trump administration you might remember
is unelected she's not been elected to
anything she's not confirmed by the
Senate she would actually be precluded
from holding an official position
because of anti-nepotism laws she often
sits in official government
conversations she was recently
interviewed by her own spokeswoman a
State Department spokeswoman a complete
and total farce meant to create the
appearance of accountability and of
transparency and of answering questions
from the press imagine if I was in some
kind of scandal it could happen right
and I said I am going to subject myself
to questioning I will be transparent I
am going to explain to you what I did
and why I did it and I will be held to
account and I will let the press talk to
me and then it's like my own staff that
interviews me right you would say what
the hell are you doing how is this
transparency so Ivanka goes to the Doha
forum in Doha Qatar or Qatar as Tucker
Carlson calls it big announcement that
she would be speaking it's already sort
of like why is she going to be speaking
but okay she's going to be speaking this
immediately created an uproar of
questions what is she doing in Qatar is
this some kind of signal to the royal
family about something of some kind is
Jared Kushner going of course Jared
Kushner's connections to the region are
problematic at best and downright
corrupt at worst
but then she shows up the room is filled
with officials from all over the world
actual officials being interviewed by
real journalists asking actual questions
about policy and issues it's a forum
actually known
for tough interviews Lindsey Graham was
there he got into a whole thing with a
real journalist about impeachment for
example the Rwandan president was asked
about term limits which is an immediate
and very real issue in Rwanda the
president there
I believe it's Paul Paul Kagame Kagame
Kagame I believe so in comes Ivanka
Trump to be interviewed and the
interviewer is Morgan Ortega's that's
the same person I just quoted in the
last segment who told us why the Trump
administration is not going to be
recognizing the Armenian Genocide as a
genocide Morgan is the current State
Department spokesperson and a former Fox
News contributor and she throws Ivanka
utter softball questions for example you
were able to put women's prosperity into
the national security strategy that was
so important to me that you did that and
I'd love for you to explain that whoa
transparency Wow Ivanka is really going
to have to account for oh right it's
bogus
speaking of travels you've been in
Morocco recently can you tell us more
about the trip in highlights oh well we
rode camels and I met some business
owners another question you also
returned on a swing through Latin
America with our deputies Deputy
Secretary of State John Sullivan can you
tell us about some of your impressions
oh it's so vibrant and whoa what can
everyone hear that's representing the
private sector do ya that's a really
hard hitting issue and with all of the
successes of the initial launch what are
you doing to ensure that this lasts much
beyond your time in the White House a
Russian journalist said at the event
even Vladimir Putin doesn't get
interviewed by his own press secretary
this is how what are effectively
monarchs this is how monarchs are
groomed right in this case Ivanka sort
of the equivalent to the Queen's
daughter but or even the Queen right I
mean unelected unconformity in
completely over her head this is how you
groom monarchs controlled audiences
controlled questions
calculated foe transparency biased press
conferences with softball questions
would never have a role in government
were it not for her dad
not to mention remember that the Trump
kids said they were going to try to stay
out of politics at the start of Trump's
presidency that ship has obviously long
sailed she's basically asking herself
questions this is a crafted fake
interview with the spokeswoman that she
traveled there with now here's my
question is this an attempt to look
important like is this an ego thing for
a Vanka Trump is this because she simply
couldn't handle a real serious interview
is this because the people at the State
Department realized that she shouldn't
be there at all and this is how they
protect their own image by making sure
that she doesn't embarrass the State
Department by virtue of being asked real
questions by actual journalists my
question is who do you think decides
that this is what they are going to do
and what is going to be done and at what
point is it decided and for what purpose
let me know by replying if you're
watching on youtube leave a comment or
send me a tweet at D Pakman I know most
of you know that Donald Trump lies but
here's a hilarious story Trump often has
stories about his black friend or his
veteran friend that type of thing where
he says oh yeah I know my black friend
told me this or my veteran friend told
me that normal people would see how much
Trump lies and immediately suspect that
those stories are also lies trump has
been selling a telling or selling it I
guess we could say both ways he's been
telling a similar story about his Jewish
friend and every time the Jewish friend
is somebody else this is just the best
Trump told basically the same story on
September 9th December 7th and twice on
December 11th at different events the
context is always that Trump says he did
the right thing by getting out of the
Iran deal and he supports this by saying
even my Jewish friend came to me and
said the best thing wasn't you know
moving the embassy or whatever the best
thing was getting out of that Iran deal
the first time he mentioned
it was people who were telling him this
the second time Trump told the story
verbatim he said it was big Republican
donor Sheldon Adelson who told him this
then the third time he told the story it
was the owner of the New England
Patriots NFL football team Bob Kraft who
told him this and then the fourth time
that he was praised for getting out of
the Iran deal it was the father of his
son-in-law Jared Kushner Charles Kushner
check out this compilation video with
Trump telling the same story four times
each time naming somebody else
[Music]
[Music]
I said to Sheldon what do you think was
bigger Israel and the embassy going in
and it became Jerusalem the capital of
Israel or the Golan Heights he said
neither he said the biggest thing you
did for Israel was breaking up and
terminating the horrible one-sided
catastrophic deal that was made by
President Obama I said Bob Kraft which
is bigger which is more important to the
Jewish people who said neither I said
what does that mean he said what you did
by terminating the Iran nuclear deal is
bigger than both I think that's true and
then I asked Charlie Kushner I said
Charlie let me ask you what's bigger for
the Jewish people giving the embassy to
Jerusalem it becomes the capital of
Israel what's bigger that or the Golan
Heights he said neither I said what does
that mean he said the biggest thing of
all is what you did by ending the Iran
nuclear catastrophe I think that's true
apparently Trump has asked this question
many times and all of his Jewish friends
seemed to be giving him the same answer
right he's having trouble keeping the
lies straight that's what's going on we
recently did a segment about compulsive
lying and here we
are with a great example Trump lies so
much it's so second nature to him to
make stuff up that he can't keep the
lies straight or he has those delusions
where he thinks nobody will notice and
he just tells the story differently each
time for kicks much like many of the
compulsive liars that I've known in my
life and of course if you call them out
if you on December 11th after Trump did
the first event and said hey Bob Kraft
said this to me and in the second event
it was Charlie Kushner who said this to
him if you said you know you just told
the same story and named to different
people he would come up with something
he would say well it was actually both
of them who said it to me or he would
say well they both basically said the
same thing or well Kushner said it
before and Kraft said it more recently
and both stories are true I just told
them out of order I get a lot of emails
that say David this is very clear
evidence of dementia and I've said
before Trump may have cognitive decline
but Trump clearly remembers enough that
he could tell this story one way every
time if it was a real story actual
possible cognitive decline aside we're
letting him off the hook when we say
this is merely dementia this is merely
cognitive decline this is a liar who
lies so much that he probably is not
remembering which lies he's told who
he's told them to and this is what you
end up with as a final result even the
American right should be scared to death
that this guy has control over nuclear
weapons he has a huge degree of control
over the financial future of the United
States this is very scary stuff because
he's lying about insignificant things as
we know crowd size hand size I think you
know what I mean these Jewish friends
who tell him the stuff but he's also
lying about really really big things as
well and we've reported on many of them
this is scary stuff this is the stuff of
nightmares and now let's actually step
back a little bit and quantify the
dishonesty and frame it historically in
terms of what we're now experiencing so
once again we have a claim that there
are Republican senators willing ready
or interested in convicting Donald Trump
in the expected impeachment trial in the
United States Senate now we had a story
a week or two ago that had a Democratic
Senator Chris Murphy saying that there
are Republican senators he says he can
count them on one hand but that there
are Republican senators who are ready to
convict Donald Trump in the Senate there
was really no evidence of this it was
just Chris Murphy saying that that's
what he believes we have another person
saying this but this time it is a
Republican not a Democrat it's bill weld
former Republican governor of
Massachusetts who is also running I
guess in some technical sense although
it's not going anywhere a primary
campaign against Donald Trump bill weld
was interviewed by the hill and he said
quote I know most of the senior
Republicans in the Senate they're
picking their words carefully when they
talk to me of all people
even though we are friends I wouldn't
want to get quoted I don't even like to
ask someone to do something which is not
in their political self-interest but
yeah I would say there are four to six
votes for removal right now so there are
two responses to this number one is no
way and number two is so what and I'll
explain each of those responses first of
all there is no evidence right now that
there are really four to six Republican
senators ready to convict Donald Trump
on impeachment in the Senate every
indication we have so far is that they
will go against impeachment Republicans
in the Senate will you might even see a
centrist Democrat like joe Manchin also
go against impeachment in the Senate but
can we come up with a list that is at
least circumstantially reasonable of
Republicans that might vote to convict
Donald Trump sure we talked about it
last week Susan Collins in Maine often a
candidate has been an occasional critic
of Trump but the caveat is in the end
she'll say a lot of things but in the
end she'll get in line like she did with
Brett Kavanaugh and his confirmation to
the Supreme Court
Mitt Romney senator from Utah Mitt
Romney has had many public disagreements
with Donald Trump they've had very acute
a bad blood between them I guess I would
say it's conceivable Mitt Romney might
say he would impeach but previously when
asked he has not given any indication
that he would Lisa Murkowski from Alaska
her name always comes up and
they say well here's a more reasonable
Republican who might depart from
Republican orthodoxy her name is
mentioned Cory Gardner there's a couple
of others but as I said before this is
where we go from no way to so what even
a four to six Republicans vote to
convict Trump it won't remove Trump and
it will get those Republicans ostracized
by the Republican Party because remember
you need two-thirds of the Senate that's
67 senators to vote to convict in order
to remove the president there are 45
Democrats and two independents that
caucus with the Democrats that means you
need to find 20 Republicans if you have
maybe four to six you don't have the
numbers now the argument would be in
order to be thorough here the argument
would be if there are already four to
six Republicans and we haven't even had
a trial there could be more coming
there could be momentum the best path to
making removal of Trump a reality is
something that's not going to happen
which is if the Senate passes a measure
to make make impeachment votes a secret
ballot where they vote privately instead
of publicly this way you could have
exactly 20 Republicans vote to impeach
it would get Trump removed but no one
would initially know which were the 20
that voted to convict but again there is
no indication that there exists a
political appetite for this in the
Republican Party and the question also
is could such a measure even be passed
with Mitch McConnell running the show in
the Senate as Majority Leader given that
he says the White House will be in total
coordination with him as to how the
Senate trial would be run certainly the
White House would know that a secret
ballot would not be advantageous to
Donald Trump because it would allow some
Republicans to vote to convict without
suffering the political consequences and
the wrath of Trump as a result very
difficult to imagine that Mitch
McConnell even let's that be a serious
discussion that's what we know so far
tell me what you think agree disagree if
you're watching on youtube leave a
comment of course after hitting like and
subscribe if you're watching or
listening anywhere else send me a tweet
at D Pakman and I believe we will have a
follow-up story about this on
the David Pakman show Instagram which
you can find at david pakman show on
your Instagram app Rudy Guiliani is
saying the quiet part out loud after all
this time spent arguing that he's not
involved in the Ukraine stuff he didn't
interfere they didn't push anybody out
everything was perfect the phone call
was perfect their relationships with
everybody over in Ukraine the Ambassador
to everybody else everything was just
perfect Rudy Giuliani has now admitted
to New Yorker reporter Adam entus that
yes he needed ambassador Murray
Ivanovich out of the way later going
last night on Fox News's Laura Ingraham
Ingraham program and saying I got her
out you aren't supposed to admit this
Rudy but you're certainly making it much
easier that's for sure quote from Adam
and to sin The New Yorker Rudy says I
believed that I needed you voinovich out
of the way she was going to make the
investigations difficult for everybody
Rudy goes on to admit that he was
working on a dossier not just about the
Biden's but also about Murray Ivanovich
herself and said let's make this as
prominent as possible by going on TV to
talk about it
then last night Rudy went on Fox News
and confirmed this to Laura Ingraham now
he tries to deny that he needed her out
of the way but admits that he forced her
out which is exactly what they've been
denying all this time take a look at
this clip from last night now this hit
piece and it's a hit pieces course also
has you on the record admitting that you
forced out murray ivanovitch did you
needed her out of the way but you're a
personal attorney for the present so why
do you need her out of the way I didn't
need her out of the way I've I forced
her out because she's corrupt so the
alleged hit piece that Laura Ingraham is
referencing is accurate and again Rudy's
trying to make this distinction I didn't
need her out of the way I forced her out
of the way the issue is a non-elected
non senate-confirmed non-government
person who is Donald Trump's personal
lawyer foresee
out ambassadors who are selected by
presidents this is Red Alert stuff and I
know that in the era of scandal fatigue
in the era of constant drama and
Fiasco's and scandals this stuff gets
lost but Rudy Giuliani is admitting that
he as a non-government actor saw an
ambassador as an impediment to getting
what he wanted and to Donald Trump
getting what he wanted and forced her
out he admits it he's just a lawyer
that's all he's not a government actor
this is what they have been denying all
along during the impeachment hearings
one of the main narratives that remember
the Republican lawyer during the
impeachment hearings was this guy Steve
castor and what Steve castor tried to
push was that no one was trying to push
Murray Ivanovich out everybody was fine
with her being the ambassador Trump
wasn't bothered Rudy wasn't bothered but
Trump wanted to root out corruption and
she didn't and all that stuff here is
Rudy admitting he says to - Adam entus
she was an impediment and I needed her
out of the way he says - Laura Ingraham
I got her out of the way this is very
reminiscent of when early in Donald
Trump's presidency remember when they
were denying any contact with Russians
is laughable now because of everything
we know but you had Trump denying
contact with Russians Mike Pence was
denying contact with Russians Don Jr
denied it Jeff Sessions famously denied
it he got caught lying and ended up
having to recuse himself on anything
Russia related when he was Trump's
beleaguered Attorney General now it
seems unbelievable that they were ever
denying it but at one point they were
and then you had Don junior tweet out oh
yeah we were in touch with Russians
Russian business people this Russian
that Russian but it's no big deal and
everything's fine
it's deny deny deny until it's too late
and then they don't and then they say
well no I mean oh yeah it happened but
it's totally fine the real story is some
Democrat did some other thing this time
I don't actually think it's part of a
plan by Rudy Giuliani it seems once
again he's off the reservation and this
is exactly why Rudy Giuliani was pulled
off TV multiple times early this year
very early this year
we reported on it he blundered badly in
multiple interviews and he was pulled
off for a while more recently he was
pulled off again from Fox News but he
did speak to this reporter last month he
then was back on Fox News last night and
it is as ridiculous as any of us
imagined everything is the opposite of
what they tell us
Trump was rooting out corruption no
Trump wanted smears Jovanovic was
working on corruption and Rudy wanted
her out and got her out even though
that's what they had been denying I
really hope that Rudy Giuliani ends up
testifying in the Senate impeachment
trial it would be something amazing to
see people around Trump should try to
convince Trump that it would be great
for Rudy to testify that Rudy would just
do so great of course it's not true but
that might get Trump to tell Rudy to
show up and testify in the Senate
impeachment trial and then it would just
be an amazing situation to watch Rudy
Giuliani self-destruct
never mind Trump Trump said he would
consider testifying in the impeachment
trial I can't imagine he will be allowed
anywhere near the Senate trial by his
lawyers to the extent that they can
control him but we can always hope and
that would be I mean instant
self-incrimination let me know what
you're hoping for in the Senate
impeachment trial given that a
conviction is extremely unlikely On
January 1st we will be kicking off 2020
it's insane that it's already 2020 I
remember when it was New Year's Eve 1999
and 2020 seemed comically far off and
we're just a couple weeks from it On
January 1 2020 we will have a crazy
membership special if you've been
thinking of it's an election year you
want to support alternatives to
corporate media get on our mailing list
by signing up for it at david pakman.com
subscribe to the newsletter and then on
January 1st you will get a beautiful
email a perfect email as Donald Trump
would say with an extremely
extraordinary membership special let me
know what you think about Rudy on Laura
Ingraham by sending me a tweet at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
so yesterday was not a good day for
Donald Trump not only is he reportedly
panicking as he realizes that as
unlikely as an impeachment conviction is
he is 67 votes away from being removed
from the presidency we have a new report
that says he committed multiple federal
crimes crimes not violations of his oath
of office which are bad enough by the
way and he was raging all day yesterday
once again just tweeting all day the
entire day spent tweeting and retweeting
all sorts of adjectives page report from
the House Judiciary Committee says that
Donald Trump committed criminal bribery
as well as wire fraud now this is a
really interesting report because all
along Republicans and Trump have
insisted you can't impeach if there's no
crime now of course that's wrong
impeachment is a political process that
doesn't require violating criminal law
but it just so happens that Donald Trump
now is accused of committing crimes as
well this set Trump off on another one
of these petulant childish tirades
including one tweet with all caps read
the transcripts continuing to say the
impeachment hoax is the greatest con job
in the history of American politics the
fake news media all cap capital fnm and
fake news media and their partner the
Democrat Party are working overtime to
make life for the United Republican
Party and all it stands for as difficult
as possible Trump also going on to brag
about the stock market we know that he
thinks because he has said if stocks are
doing well how do you impeach the
president
tweeting quote new stock market high I
will never get bored of telling you that
and we will never get tired of winning
now just as a reminder here's video of
Trump two weeks ago on a day that stocks
fell 400 points on the Dow saying he
doesn't watch the stock market but if
the stock market goes up or down
I don't watch this
jobs jobs are what I watched I watched
making the proper deal we've been taking
advantage of the United States like
China for so many years yeah he doesn't
talk about it on days that it's down I
think more accurately we could say then
Trump coming completely unglued about
his upcoming 20/20 reelection campaign
in a multi tweet explosion saying quote
I look very much forward to debating
whoever the lucky person is who stumbles
across the finish line in the little
watched do-nothing Democrat debates my
record is so good on the Capitol II
economy and all else including debating
that perhaps I would consider more than
three debates the problem is that the
so-called Commission on presidential
debates is stacked with Trump haters and
never Trump errs three years ago they
were forced to publicly apologize for
modulating my microphone in the first
debate against crooked Hillary this is
the president tweeting folks as
president the debates are up to me and
there are many options including doing
them directly and avoiding the nasty
politics of this very biased Commission
I will make a decision at an appropriate
time but in the meantime the Commission
on Presidential Debates
is not authorized to speak for me or
Republicans now we're gonna dig more
into this debate stuff on the bonus show
today and I know that producer Pat has
many things that he wants to say about
it
Trump then continuing all day I mean it
is all day long retweeting endless
propaganda videos from Fox News and Rudy
Giuliani the narrative being it's all a
con job everyone's been tricked
they're attacking him unfairly it's all
unbelievable so don't be tricked
Trump is raging because he got caught
but he still might get away with it they
did it in public crimes in real-time
some on live television some on Twitter
witness tampering intimidation all this
different stuff and the right is helping
Trump turn himself into a scapegoat or
even a martyr one of the biggest
differences between Nixon's 1970s and
Trump now is that Nixon didn't have the
benefit of not only a degree of
partisanship that listen people always
say we've never seen partisanship like
this before that's true but there's
always been partisanship but it is worse
that now than it was during the 1970s
but also this fact free alternative fact
post truth thing which we will talk
about later today which makes it so that
no matter what happens you have a media
apparatus that will excuse defend or
counter accuse no matter what it is that
Donald Trump has done and unfortunately
they will likely get away with it in
terms of impeachment maybe not but they
will likely get away with it and we
can't let them get away with it
in the November of 2020 election
although I I know I'm supposed to always
pretend that everything is great and
everything IIIi don't know that Donald
Trump is going to be denied reelection
in November of 2020 I'm scared I am
going to address this more a little bit
later on this week I have some
delightfully cringe-worthy video for you
today I almost fell off my chair I
cringed so hard when I saw this Fox News
did a segment this was part of Fox and
Friends apparently they brought on a
conservative squad and by that they mean
a right-wing response to the squad of
actual members of Congress all of whom
were members of the Democratic Party and
of diverse backgrounds Fox News's
conservative squad is not of diverse
backgrounds it's four congressional
candidates who are running to fight
socialism among other things in the
United States they want to be the anti
squad effectively now you'll hear the
host name the candidates so I won't this
is maybe the dumbest thing I've heard on
a few levels which were going to discuss
shortly at first I was convinced this
was a Saturday Night Live parody but
it's not the women are all obviously
white presumably so-called Christians
and it is actually difficult to watch
because this doesn't appear to be a
parody they actually seem to be serious
here let's take a look public in Alabama
congressional candidate Jessica Taylor
joins us now with conservative squad
we have Minnesota congressional
candidate Michele Fishbach South
Carolina congressional candidate Nancy
mace and Texas congressional candidate
Beth van
thank you ladies for being with us
Jessica congratulations you actually did
this yes ma'am when you want these
ladies that want to form a conservative
squad with you what goes through your
mind you know I'm just honored that they
want to join in this fight and that's
exactly what it is you know we are
losing the younger generations of this
country and I'm so grateful that they're
willing to join up and helping us cause
okay Michelle why did you want to be a
part of the squad you know this is about
bringing the conservative message to the
people of the United States so that
people understand that we're looking at
do-nothing Democrats they are obsessing
about impeachment and not really doing
anything for the people of the United
States anymore you need to take a look
at western Minnesota the district that I
live in and they're they're ignoring us
NCA they finally gotten around to it a
year later but the farmers out in
western Minnesota need us MCA and they
waited and waited but they have plenty
of time for impeachment and the Sham
that that is and they just continue to
to obsess about that and not do the
things that the people of the United
States really need these are the types
of talking points that only work in the
media equivalent of like a medical
cleanroom or maybe better said a media
safe space we are losing the younger
generation
well yeah Republican policy has
destroyed the earnings potential and
savings potential of the younger
centered generation college costs have
exploded the students and the younger
people are riddled with student debt
wages are stagnant and they don't have
health care so yeah you're gonna lose
young people as a result of that the
do-nothing Dems they say well Democrats
don't control the Senate and between
Mitch McConnell and Donald Trump's veto
power at the White House they can do
very very little farmers are struggling
and we really need us MC a well the
farmers are struggling because of Donald
Trump's trade policy they don't mention
that of course every single one of these
dumb talking points would be dismantled
instantly and anything but a safe space
and they are being held up these four
women as some kind of moral right wing
Crusaders and it gets even worse let's
continue the video Nancy why is the
squat important to you well you know if
you look at my life I got my start as a
waitress at Waffle House I became the
first woman to graduate from the city
the Military College of South Carolina
20 years ago today I'm a businesswoman
and state lawmaker running for the
United States Congress and this is about
our future this is the American dream
and you see the Democrats they've taken
a sharp left turn under the influence of
the socialist squad and you look at us
and this is socialism versus American
values of freedom and job creation and
we all understand up here today that
people flourish under freedom and 2020
next year is pivotal for our country and
you know we see so many women across the
the country right now Republican Women
who are picking up the mantle and want
to serve they say enough is enough my
kids in my country are worth fighting
for and that's what this is about
essentially Beth how about you well I
look at right now we really do have a
Congress it's run by extremists and it's
dangerous for America because they're
not doing anything we haven't seen
solutions for out of control health care
costs this is not socialism versus
anything there are almost no socialists
in the United States in prominent
positions of power at the national level
the idea that the squad or the
Democratic Party or Democrats or whoever
are pushing socialism is ridiculous this
is a false debate the country has not
gone hard left the country increasingly
realizes that the things that they have
in other capitalist countries like
Norway and Finland Denmark Canada
Australia Sweden things like health care
and education we should also have and as
a rich country we can also afford to
have that's not socialism that's not far
left this reminds me of Trump's last
State of the Union address you might
remember it from yelled out at the last
State of the Union I think it was the
last one maybe the previous but I'm
pretty sure it was the last he yelled
out too much Republican applause in the
crowd we will never be a socialist
nation there's no risk of that right now
but to say ever nobody knows what could
happen in a long time but who is trying
to make this a socialist country I get
it there are some socialists okay but
actual socialists in positions of power
are few and far between they're not
making policy they are you know when you
talk about tuition free call
paid out of taxes we're people who get
really rich from their businesses pay
more that's a capitalist thing that
happens in socialism you wouldn't have
those ultra rich people except when the
socialist state is a corrupt state in
which case you wouldn't that happens but
then they probably wouldn't be paying
high taxes single-payer health care is a
capitalist idea where the fruits of
capitalism are used to make sure
everyone has health care regardless of
whether they can personally afford it
based on the job that they have they are
setting up this fake enemy of socialism
when they are really fighting more
progressive capitalists that's really
the majority of what the the ideas are
that they claim to be fighting as far
left it's total cringe but the really
scary thing about this the thing that is
depressing is that in a lot of parts of
the country this stuff probably is
appealing I understand that as someone
who lives in Massachusetts I laugh when
I see stuff like this but because it
seems almost like a parody but there are
parts of the country where folks like
these could actually win and we need to
be activating and organizing against
them because otherwise they will win and
even if it's a fake war against
socialism that they think they're waging
they can still be successful as long as
they prevent serious progressive reforms
from actually taking place so I know
that we laugh it off in a lot of parts
of the country and we joke in this is a
Fox News echo chamber these folks are
never going to get elected nobody's
going to fall for the false the the
straw men that they are putting together
that's not true in a lot of parts of the
country this stuff resonates and sadly I
mean even here in Massachusetts in some
of the more rural parts you see a
sympathy for this type of ideology so
we've got to fight every district we've
got to fight every race we've got to
fight all the way to and through the
November of 2020 election if we want a
shot at this because this the they are
tricking people they are convincing
people and as scary as it is as
laughable as it is also in many ways
we've got to fight it at every
opportunity